all right I think what probably from my
perspective I reckon what happened was
that there was that pressure on women to
be you know you've got to look amazing
all the time and blokes like back in the
the sort of the 80s and early 90s and
stuff guys didn't really have to make an
effort you know what I mean it was like
you could have a beer garden it's like
whatever football shirt on and she's
like yeah she's nice and you know it's
very laddy
pictures of guys from like I saw beach
pictures from like the before the 60s
everyone was hot back then there was so
much more attractive well I think well
and the women they were I feel like
something switched in the food or
something well yeah maybe in maybe just
in England then but no I know what you
mean because I've seen in pictures in
like Brazil and stuff like from the 70s
yeah that's like in the US like
California pictures oh really yeah okay
okay